welcome to the kirby center I'm John
Miller directed the Dow journalism
program at the campus in Hillsdale as
Matt Spalding said he started out by
referring to this to this painting when
when when Matt looks at this painting he
sees a bunch of founding fathers and I
suppose I suppose we all do but but what
first comes to mind for me is the artist
Sam connect who is an art professor at
the college I last saw Sam about a day
and a half ago when I was picking up my
13 year old from his house at ten
o'clock at night from a Halloween party
the connects had invited the entire
eighth grade class from Hillsdale
Academy over the house for a halloween
party and boy with sam relieved to see
the parents showing up to to take all
the kids home so i want to see this pain
and i think of sam also when i look at
this painting I think of journalism
because in the painting I see a couple
of really important journalists so we
have James Madison in the yellow I'm
sorry Alexander and James Nelson's the
little guy right Little Jimmy Madison as
i used to say we Alexander Hamilton in
the yellow and Hamilton was many things
but one of the most important things he
did and one of the most lasting of his
legacies is he founded the New York Post
which we still have today it is one of
the longest continuously published
newspapers in America I think it is
about the sixth or the seventh most read
in America today and of course its its
its most famous for its front-page
headlines right headless woman in
topless bar you know that's that's the
New York Post and we have Alexander
Hamilton to thank for that and there he
is in the picture um the other the other
big press guy in this picture is right
next to him seated is Benjamin Franklin
right again Benjamin Franklin did many
things in his life but what did he do
first he was a printer he was basically
a newspaper man he was America's first
media mogul
and and it was the wealth he generated
as a newspaper publisher as the
publisher of Poor Richard's Almanack
which is one of the most successful
publications ever in American history
the wealth he made as a printer is what
allowed him to go into public life and
become an ambassador in London to sit at
the Constitutional Convention and so
forth but he made his fortune in
journalism and in publishing and
printing and then he became a statesman
met also mentioned a fellow who's not
here in this picture Thomas Jefferson
well before we get to that I'm just
looking at the wall over there that
picture on the wall over there that's a
newspaper it's the Providence Gazette
and country journal the seven of the the
in addition from 1787 the reason it's
hanging on the wall there is because it
published the Constitution so these guys
what they wrote they didn't you know
attach the document as a PDF file to
their emails and send it to all their
friends Americans read the Constitution
for the first time in their newspapers
and they read it in newspapers just like
the one we have framed over there so
again journalism is essential to what to
what these guys were doing now boy that
the print is really tiny on this thing I
don't out of Dave they must have bet
eagle eyes back then or something but
that's hard to read at any rate the man
not pictured in this in this one of them
is is Thomas Jefferson not a newspaper
man he once said the man who never looks
into a newspaper is better informed than
he who reads them a sentiment we can
perhaps all understand Jefferson um
deliberately did not engage in
journalism he never wrote for newspapers
the way many of these guys did he made
the conscious decision not to but boy
was he interested in what they were
saying he was deeply involved in
manipulating the press in trying to
control the press and having it say
things that would help his partisan
causes in the 1790s and beyond I'm going
to say a little bit more about
all that in in a moment but but
Jefferson was a great complainer when it
came to the press and we conservatives
are really good at complaining about
journalism too aren't we we're always
complaining about the quality of it and
so forth reminds me of a joke have you
heard have you heard the one about the
reporter who asked Hillary Clinton a
really tough question neither have I if
you think of a punch line though I'm
ready to hear it so we're really good at
complaining about about the quality of
the media and journalism were practiced
at it we need to get better at making
journalism great and let's remember
these guys thought journalism was really
important all right and we should too we
need to complain about it but we can't
scoff at it and we can't disregard it we
need to think about how can we make
journalism great one thing we need to do
is make great journalists that is a
thing we can do it is a long term
project but as a thing we we can do I'm
going to say a few words about how we
might do that and also why the
opportunity to do it for conservatives
has never been better than it is right
now all right so that's where I'm headed
but i do want to complain a little bit
more who watched the CNBC debate the
other night I mean neat neat need we say
no more than that about how awful the
moderation of that was there were some
fine moments in that debate they happen
despite the moderators not because of
them in fact the great moments that
happened because of the madres when the
candidates were complaining directly at
them about their unfairness right you
can't have watched that debate and not
realize we don't have a problem the
other the other the other thing we've
been we've been grumbling about recently
did you see the report about how the New
York Times refers to ben Carson and Jill
Biden Jill Biden the second lady she is
that she holds a doctorate she earned a
doctorate in education
so of course New York Times on second
reference constantly calls her doctor
bite and dr. Biden dr. Biden then we
have ben Carson a Republican
presidential candidate an actual medical
doctor who saves babies and improves the
lives of children and is a genius in the
surgery room apparently he's always mr.
Carson mr. Carson in the New York Times
the analysis i saw it's not always that
sometimes they actually do calm dr.
Carson but the analysis I saw is that
Jill Biden is about three times as
likely as ben Carson to be referred to
as a doctor in the pages the New York
Times this is a subtle thing but it's a
real thing and one thing one thing they
teach you in journalism is the
importance of style and consistency
right this is a technical aspect of
journalism importance of consistency
every newspaper has its style sheet so
for example when you refer to a state
you know someone if you're from
Hillsdale Michigan right how do you
write out michigan do you write out
michigan du du mich period do you do mi
in capital letters like it's on it like
you're dressing an envelope what do you
do you get these style sheets of
publications so that everybody is doing
the same thing for purposes of
identification it's a very technical
aspect publications have different rules
but they try to be above all consistent
alright so the New York Times is
violating its own policy with this a
fundamental rule of journalism has
nothing to do the politics at a certain
level but of course we don't has
everything to do with politics right
they don't want to call this guy a
doctor now I do want to emphasize um I
do not think that 99% of journalists
should give the rest a bad name it took
you a moment right yeah look look
there's a lot of there's a lot of bad
everything right in Washington DC
there's a lot of bad lawyering in
Silicon Valley there's bad software
programming for all I know at Union
Station there's bad shoe shining and
there's a lot of bad journalism there's
going to be a lot of bad journalism no
matter what one of the crucial
differences though is that is the
journalism is on public display for
everyone
to see and this is a hard thing with my
students especially when they start
taking journalism classes I you know I
said the first thing you need to do one
of the first things you need to develop
a thick skin you're going to be writing
for the school newspaper if you write a
lousy paper you know on Aristotle or
whatever for your politics course you
get a see you can kind of hide that not
tell anybody it can be your little
secret between you and the professor if
you write a thing in the campus paper
though and it causes controversy have
fun with that right you will hear about
it from your fellow students and if you
have a typo they'll point that out if
they don't like a thing you said they
want to argue with you they will do that
this is a public profession in a way a
lot of things aren't there's a public
aspect to everything we do but but when
you're a journalist ever you are on
display all the time and so we see the
badness of and we're going to see the
badness of it there's no getting around
that there's a different kind of badness
though when it comes to journalism
that's the badness of bias and we see
that all the time as well it distorts
reality like a funhouse mirror and then
maddeningly the people who committed
deny that we've walked into a freak show
right that's the most aggravating thing
about it is the denial that exists by
the people perpetrating it they refuse
to admit what do they always say oh I'm
objective and they might even admit well
yeah I'm a liberal I vote such in such a
way but you know that doesn't affect my
news coverage I mean I'm objective when
I'm a reporter right we've all heard
this we've all seen the statistics and
we know it's not true Becky Quick on
CNBC remember her question about women
earning 77 cents on the dollar compared
to men first of all number one that's a
democratic talking point number two um
you work at CNBC you're supposed to know
a little bit about economics I mean what
a bogus figure that was and Marco Rubio
handled that question while I thought
but I just thought you know he also got
to lashed out at her you what are you
doing here that's a lie that figure is a
lie and she could have asked the same
question to to elicit a kind of respond
she wanted with a different figure or
just ask the question without it but
that statistic is a lie and there she
was a national television throwing it
out like it's the truth now some
journalists um really do wake up every
morning wondering how can I stick it to
conservatives today right John Harwood
comes to mind the the most um the most
embarrassing moment I thought during the
debate forum from the moderator side was
when he challenged marco rubi on his tax
plan based upon a misreading of it that
he had already been forced to correct
and had corrected it and yet went back
to the same mistake when he was on
national television to challenge rubio
and if you remember that moment but it
was astonishing and was you know i was
watching the whole thing i was watching
it on TV but then following on twitter
you know 15 minutes later people were
pulling off you know Twitter here's the
link to john Harwood's correction of the
story that was wrong of our Rubio's tax
plan than a little bit later the Tax
Foundation comes out you know the source
he's citing the tax foundation comes out
and says Rubio's right Harwood's wrong I
mean my goodness that's just shearing
competence butBut yeah butBut if you're
not if you're not digging down and do it
you think Oh some smart people think
Rubio's tax plan doesn't add up whatever
right that's the impression you you walk
away with so i don't know about john
harwood but I actually think most
liberal journalists don't wake up
thinking how am I going to stick it to
conservatives today they wind up
sticking it to conservatives but that's
not their conscious plan sometimes they
just don't know any better their bias
affects everything they do and they
don't even see it they're like fish and
water and they don't know they're
swimming in water that's what it's like
that I think is the the secret of
liberal media bias and they say things
like yeah I might be a liberal but I'm
objective well it infects all they do
some ancient style sheets a moment ago
you may have seen a year or two ago the
Associated Press on its style sheet set
we are no longer going to refer to
illegal aliens in illegal
immigrants we're not going to use those
terms anymore why because people can't
be illegal data I you've heard this
before right but they're not going to
use it this term that most Americans
understand they understand what it means
and the AP is saying we're going to not
use this anymore in any of our reporting
the AP whose words wind up probably in
just about every newspaper in America
they're not going to use those terms
right that's a political choice that's a
political choice but no no they're being
objective we'll still cover this
phenomenon of undocumented migration
whatever in the world they're calling it
these days but they're not going to use
those terms now words and phrases matter
we know this George Orwell knew it
nineteen eighty-four his most famous
book maybe along with Animal Farm is
basically about the importance of words
and how they can control us and if you
control language how you can control
society and why totalitarian societies
must control language so they can
control people that's what 1984 is about
remember news speak double think right
this is all this is this is what it's
about and so so in in in 1984 Wars piece
right that's double think yourself
totally holding two contradictory
thoughts and believing in both and so on
and you actually believe the lies you're
telling when you speak these words
that's what Orwell is all about you know
and you think about it it affects
everything we do I mean we call this
thing that CNBC did we call that a
debate that wasn't a debate right we
call it a debate because we're used to
calling these things debates you know I
don't know what was it a multi-candidate
forum of what a roast you know it was it
was sort of a you know it had had a head
had a little flavor of a press
conference to it you know and there were
there were a couple times when Canada's
actually exchanged with each other sort
of felt like a debate for you know a
little little flash but then they went
back to another thing what they're doing
has its utility but it's not a debate
right we call it that but it's not a
debate all right so so so basic words
were using are wrong all the time and
boy do these words matter there was a
study a number of years ago that some
psychologists ran
and they brought a bunch of people into
an auditorium and they showed them a
film of two cars colliding and everybody
watched this and then they split up into
two groups and one group after having
seen this film now in another room with
us at what speed where the car is
traveling when they crash together and
people wrote down their answers and the
next room and they said I'm making this
up but you'll get the point they said
all their traveling at 50 miles an hour
when they crash together then in the
next room they asked everybody at what
speed where the cars traveling when they
made contact with each other crashed and
made contact crash said it was like 50
miles an hour made contact was like 30
miles an hour right the words we use
change our perceptions of reality now
the people who did this study they were
interested in juries and memories for
four witnesses and court trials and so
on you can see why this would matter for
a thing like that but we also see how
changing a single word alters our
perception of reality right so when we
choose single words we're changing what
people think about politics or well
understood this we need to do a better
job of understanding it I'm even the
word even the word conservative is
problematic right we use it because
we're used to using it describes a
certain kind of person United States
it's a diverse movement we kind of get
it when someone's an american
conservative you know what that means
have you ever noticed that when they
talk about conservatives in Iran who
they're talking about I remember during
the Cold War who the conservatives in
the Kremlin were these are the bad guy
hardliners by the way the ones who
opposed Reagan more than anybody else
but as you go on your tour of the world
with American journalists and you hear
about the conservative forces in Islam
or the conservative forces in in Cuba or
North Korea or whatever they're talking
about a thing that is diametrically
different from what conservatives are in
the United States so all the time we're
using the word
servet of in ways that imply certain
things to readers of newspapers Watchers
of television shows and so on you call
someone a conservative Kremlin
conservative it makes a kind of sense I
understand why they're doing that you
know small see conservative is kind of a
relative distinction between other
people boys it load it and and many of
them don't even know they're doing it a
few know they're doing it what they're
doing though is is is causing causing
trouble the very worst journalist of
course flirt with the totalitarianism
that George Orwell opposed last December
at the University of Iowa they had some
visiting professor who wanted to want to
make an anti-racist sculpture and place
it on campus you know because because we
need to do that on campuses and so he
makes a sculpture of a Klansman and and
and and sir dresses him in like
newspaper print and I don't quite get
what he was going for but he made this
this this statute puts it in the middle
of campus at the University of Iowa and
supposed to be some kind of anti racist
statement right what you can imagine
what happened next the sort of offense
that was taken the controversy this
cause you know the removal and so on at
the time though the guy who runs the
journalism program at the University of
Iowa said this name's david rife our Y
Fe he said if it was up to me and me
alone I would follow the lead of every
European nation and banned this type of
speech when you have journalism
professors talking about banning speech
we have a problem right i mean this guy
should be kind of a you kind of want him
to be a hardliner on the First Amendment
and yet he's not you know who does band
speech the Cubans the North Koreans the
Saudi Arabians the Iranians those are
the people who banned speech and the
journalism chief at the University of
Iowa now his timing could not have been
worse because what happens two weeks
later
a bunch of crazed gunman storm a
magazine office in France and kill a
dozen people in the Charlie Hebdo
massacre they wanted to ban speech too
and they are willing to deal with guns
and violence not with laws so his timing
was awkward and it's easy to it's easy
to march and say we're all charlie
remember that that's Logan from last
January and forever you know we're all
Charlie it's harder to post it's harder
to print the first post Massacre
magazine cover of that magazine we all
saw it remember the green background had
Mohammed on serve a cartoon Muhammad on
it the New York Times didn't publish it
they didn't publish it I'm not
unsympathetic to that decision that's a
hard thing you know these jury you know
you don't you don't want to be the next
target but you know what the New York
Times did publish they published piss
Christ remember that thing that our
government funded back in nineteen
ninety or whenever it was a crucifix
submerge a photograph of a crucifix
submerged in urine called piss Christ
funded by the NEA they published that
they also published the image of a
picture and image called called Holy
Virgin Mary by an artist named chris
ofili that was put on display in a
museum in Brooklyn it had a picture of
Mary covered in elephant dung and
pornography the inner Times published
that too I guess they're not worried
about the Christian terrorists but think
about it you know if you're going to do
one thing do the other if you're going
to offend offend everybody or offend
nobody but these are the choices they're
making these are the choices they make
all the time and those are flamboyant
examples but I want to say it actually
drills down to the level the words they
use to describe the events that they're
objectively covering their objective
they're always objective now when the
founders wrote the constant
ocean when this was happening they
actually lived in an era of wild
partisanship in the media the um you
know if you think if you think well
Alexander Hamilton why did he start the
New York Evening Post he called The
Evening Post at the time he started the
New York Evening Post because he
couldn't stand Thomas Jefferson he
wanted the New York Post to become an
anti Jeffersonian mouthpiece for the
Federalist Party that's why he started
the new york post for a specifically
political objective and again at this
time if you think Twitter is mean today
if you think the comments section at the
bottom of your favorite blog are really
nasty you should see what the newspapers
were saying about these guys back at
that time you know we have this image of
Washington you know this revered figure
you know nobody criticized George
Washington everybody loved George
Washington everybody respected
Washington kind of in fact he was a
target of fierce press criticism in the
1790s you know we hear all this stuff
you know he had no intention of becoming
a monarch he did all these things to
prevent people from thinking as becoming
am honored one of the reasons we hear
this because he was denying it all the
time because he's being accused of it
all the time by the opposition press ok
so so journalism back then was was wild
there were few rules it was deeply
partisan and if they managed to give us
the Constitution not a bad outcome and
for many years for decades our press was
was was aligned with parties we see
vestiges of it today with something like
the Arkansas democrat-gazette you know
the word Democrat right in the title the
big newspaper in Tallahassee Florida is
also called is called the Tallahassee
Democrat you ever heard of the
Springfield Republican write a newspaper
in Massachusetts I'm not sure Republican
it is anymore but they still called that
and the reason it has that name is
because it was specifically aligned with
the party so we see vestiges of that
today although we don't really have the
same kind of thing right where they're
not explicitly aligned with parties
what happened what happened is that we
had the rise of objectivity and this
happened in journalism for two reasons
one of them commercial the other
ideological the commercial reason was
you had all these newspapers around
America that were that were that we're
aligning themselves with parties and
some people have any idea wouldn't it be
great if we could sell our copies to
everybody not just half the country you
know i'd like to sell to republicans and
democrats how do we do that well in when
the mexican war started a bunch of
newspapers pooled their resources to
send reporters down to mexico to cover
to cover that conflict it's expensive to
send reporters abroad they pulled
together to get the resource and this
was the birth of the associated press
and the idea was they're going to report
on events and they're going to provide
their information their copy back to all
the subscribers to this service right
well these guys had to be above
partisanship because they were they were
selling their their their copy to
Republican papers to Democrat papers and
so on so they started to they started to
not speak in his partisan ways they
started to write in ways that weren't
quite as partisan they did it for
commercial reason right so this starts
happening in the middle of the of the
19th century and then we get the
progressive movement later on the
progressive movement with its cult of
expertise of technocratic expertise
along with the weakening of political
parties and together you get sort of the
professionalization of journalism you
get this notion that just as we can have
scientific experts running the
government for us and telling us what's
good for it and sort of the is with the
birth of the administrative state we get
the same kind of thing in journalism
we're going to experts running
journalism reporting on for us and
they're going to be above politics you
know just like the bureaucrats we know
how that turned out with the
bureaucracies and with the IRS scandals
you just gone through and so on
everything is deeply politicized in the
administrative state they deny it but
it's all deeply politicized well the
same thing happened in journalism okay
so they baked the liberalism right into
the cake when this happened so we wind
up with the cult of objectivity by about
the middle of the 20th century and
and and we only have you know we have a
number of news sources but they're also
limited in a way remember when there are
only three new stations you could want
you know the evening news you're going
to watch three stations now back then
well all that's falling apart these
mainstream media vehemence I mean was
the last time anybody in this room
actually sat down and watched the
nightly news at six o'clock on one of a
major network right I mean 20 years ago
we are all doing it and we knew you know
we knew who the anchors were can you
guys even named an anchor who is even
the anchor of ABC News now I have no
idea right we know who it was in the 80s
though who was it in the 80s well he was
CBS Peter Jennings and then Tom broke we
remember who used to do it we don't know
who does it right now and that's that's
as simple and my students my goodness
they don't even know who used to do it
right there they have no they have no
idea they have no idea who these people
were right they inhabit and we remember
what what what the old world of me they
used to look like our students do they
have no clue at all I mean I can tell
them about it but they haven't
experienced it right by the way the
thing I had the thing I say to people
we're about two years away from a
college freshman knows no memory of 911
then yeah I just like how time flies
right I realized when I first got to
Hillsdale four years ago I realized this
was going to be a problem the sort of
you know my aging when I made a
reference to the TV show cheers and and
not a single kid knew what i was talking
about like oh wow have to update my my
my cultural references but anyway we
remember when when when there was sort
of this is this monolithic control over
the news it was just a few rooms in
America and they all kind of thought
alike and so on now when I was a young
journalist which was I graduated more
than more than 20 years ago and I came
to Washington I was a conservative i
wanted to do conservative journalism
well what what were the options
right there was you know you get a job
in the mainstream media and lots of
conservatives did right let's not forget
that that has happened but that's hard
it's intimidating back then what was
there there was yea though so the
Washington star was defunct with the
Washington Times existed so there were
there were a handful of newspapers with
may be friendly editorial pages here or
around the country there was um The Wall
Street Journal National Review which is
where I eventually went to work but boy
you know we're counting on one hand
that's what the scene looked like when i
graduated in nineteen eighty-two in fact
my first job in journalism I came to
Washington I work for the New Republic
the left-leaning magazine my boss was
Fred Barnes right so you know Fred hired
me but but that's what is like it's a
lot different then well you know a lot
of things started happening though in
1988 we had the Reagan administration
repealed the Fairness Doctrine the
so-called Fairness Doctrine suddenly we
have the birth of talk radio on the am
dial which conservatives came to
dominate fox news started in 1996 and
within four or five or six years it was
the number one provider of news on on
cable and you probably seen they've been
they've been gloating about this ever
since they have their damn their big ads
about how badly they beat CNN and MSNBC
but the really the really important most
disruptive factor was was the internet
and it just changed everything at
National Review you know we put out a
magazine every other week you know we're
not not as fast as a weekly we're now
slow as a monthly right we're a
fortnightly it's an odd format but when
i joined National Review that was the
pace you know filing copy every other
week and so on and then you know within
actually a few months am i joining the
staff we had National Review
line and suddenly it's every day every
hour every minute and how fast can you
post it transformed the culture of
National Review but the bottom line is
we the internet the internet cause this
this crack up and we've seen this
incredible proliferation of publications
right some are our legacy publications
National Review has been around for a
while you can still see the washington
times online and so on but we have what
the Daily Caller the Washington free
beacon the washington examiner what else
where else we get our news from the who
i J review which is the thing I'd never
even heard of a year ago and suddenly
it's dominating social media all these
all these news organizations rising up
and giving voice to conservative ideas
like never before and so what we have
today is an environment that's an awful
lot like what these guys faced right we
have we have news organizations that are
if not partisan at least explicit and
what their commitments are yeah we're
conservative or libertarian and many are
liberal we still have well we still have
plenty of journalists who insist that
their objective and so forth but we we
we don't really we don't believe we
never believed it but boy we don't
believe it we don't believe it now we
Revere the founders and we need to
remember how important journalism was to
who they were what they did and what
they accomplished what were the
Federalist Papers we buy them now in a
book and read them like a text that's
how our students at Hillsdale College
encounter like it's a book you pull off
the shelf The Federalist Papers were
op-eds they were newspaper op-eds
they've just been collected and brought
together and numbered that's what we've
done now so we actually don't remember
that they're op eds we don't think of
them as journalism but that's what they
were they were newspaper op-eds if
Thomas Paine were alive today he would
be an excellent blogger and common sense
would be an e-book
one of my favorite journalists from this
era is a fella named James Callender who
is journalists don't speak about him
very much at all because he's a little
disreputable they don't talk about him
in journalism school but he broke two of
the biggest stories in American history
in the 1790s he wrote the story that
exposed Alexander Hamilton's adultery
and if um has anybody seen that the
musical Hamilton this big thing that's
in New York now that you may you may
have heard about it this actually it's a
piece of that musical what when we think
of you know who are the great who's the
greatest founding father who didn't
become president it's probably Alexander
Hamilton maybe Ben Franklin but but you
know Hamilton maybe top set list you
know he's the guy on her currency who is
not a president right why didn't he
become president there are a bunch of
reasons he didn't become president one
is because he had to admit an adulterous
affair in the 1790s that this journalist
James Callender exposed well then what
happened fast forward a few years
calendar got really hacked off at
President Jefferson he had been he had
been a mouthpiece for Jefferson trying
to hurt Hamilton the 1790s then
Jefferson made him mad and he switched
sides so what's the what's the next big
story he broke Sally Hemings he gave us
a Sally Hemings story now he was
reporting a rumor and you know his
standards were really low about about
what he was willing to put into print
right I mean his sourcing on that was
bad and and it would not have gotten
into the campus paper at Hillsdale
College right but you got to give it to
the guy we're still talking about that
one right my point is you know we think
about you know oh the journal you know
journalist today the paparazzi and the
journal they're prying into our private
lives and and exposed they did it to
these guys okay these guys knew about
that as much as we know about that
that's important thing to remember just
just this environment
they were in and now I've actually come
to see this as a great corrective mass
spalding a few moments ago said you know
we need to be more political not less
political more political when it comes
to judicial nominations let's talk about
politics let's not pretend we're not
talking about politics when we really
are let's talk about politics and be
explicit with what we believe and what
our principles are and so forth let's be
as political as possible I think your
journalism should be the same way and
that's not to say journalists should let
me number one for your journalist tell
the truth but tell the truth is you see
it declare your biases have
conversations and we'll all be better
for it that's the system that's the
system we want and that's why it is
easier for young conservatives get jobs
in the media than ever before because
there are all these publications and
I'll tell you they are hungry they're
starving for hillsdale college students
or conservative students from any campus
in America really if they can write well
if they're willing to work hard this is
a rare commodity I mean with with our
doubt journalism program we don't even
come close to talk to filling the ranks
of these publications but but nobody
does this is actually we have a human
capital deficit in the conservative
movement when it comes to media and
journalism and we need to a better job
of producing these young people so at
Hillsdale we of the Dow journalism
program where we focus on doing it
through our campus paper and our
internships and I've been doing it now
for four years we've had one of our
graduates is now at the wall street
journal editorial page we have another
another fox news they've even gone down
to write for the Daily Beast and slate
National Review we're taking over
National Review and my favorite example
though is last my favor East an example
though is is last May we had a young man
graduate and he is now working at Guns &
Ammo magazine in Peoria Illinois which I
love because I'll guarantee you the
Columbia School of Journalism has never
produced a kid who went on go work at
Guns & Ammo magazine but but but we do
that at National Review
and.and are at Hillsdale College and one
more thing we're you know we're here
today to dedicate the the radio studio
here at the kirby center you guys are
going to see you're going to see how
great it is and what an excellent tool
this is going to be for extending the
mission of the college and talking about
politics and principles to as wide an
audience as possible we just started a
radio station on campus it's a low-power
FM signal right now we're just playing a
playlist of patriotic songs but we're
working toward a moment when we have an
adult grown-up station manager who
involves students and gets them
practicing the art of rhetoric on the
radio why are we doing this because we
want to make sure our students can
communicate and tell stories and have
interviews as well as possible and
that's going to serve them no matter
what they do it's going to serve them
well if they want to if a student wants
to be the next Hugh Hewitt come to our
radio station and practice but I'll tell
you what if you want to be a lawyer if
you want to be a candidate for office if
you want to be a teacher come practice
it at our radio station we're moving
towards that and so that's that's that's
just now getting off the ground so we're
that's that's another thing we're doing
to help change the culture of of media
and journalism so so what you're here
today for the dedication is is one
aspect of that we're going to be linking
the studio here with the station in in
in Hillsdale and start to do great
things so I think that will probably
always complain about liberal media bias
but we need to start doing something
about it and and and I'll contend the
solution to liberal media bias is
conservative journalists and we need to
produce more we need to make more and
help them take advantage of the unique
opportunity we find ourselves in today
that didn't exist a generation ago so
thanks very much will do will do some
questions and we've got young ladies
with microphones if someone want to
raise your hand they'll give you might
ask ask into the microphone and we'll
we'll go here and then then with um then
this guy John
stretch what is it that's a that's a
great question so so there are a few
ways I have fun with this one of the
things I like to do with with my
students often on you know the first day
at class and one of my journalism
classes I'll say I'll say what's a you
know I'll say what's a newspaper for and
they'll raise their hands and they'll
give me these Ernest answers about you
know informing the citizenry and stuff
like that and and I'll remind them a
newspaper is is is is for making money
to business right let's never forget
that there are publishers who are trying
to make a living at this and and and and
and so on you know having said that we
need to step back and talk about what is
quality journalism how they can that
contribute to a successful business
model i define journalism as the
literature of what's just happened you
know telling true telling the truth
about events we've we've we've seen or
observed that's what journalism is i
define it pretty broadly is everybody a
journalist sometimes you hear that i
don't quite believe that there are some
standards to journalism and so on but
ultimately we need we need journalistic
organizations that earn our trust so
they're through they're through their
professionalism their actual their real
objectivity not their phony objectivity
and journalism can be an awful lot of
things but but it's it's it's telling us
what just happened with this gentleman
here
sometimes yes it's a you know fish wrap
by Friday yep yep I have not seen it
this is the dan Rather film so um dan
Rather um I say put he know he put the
BS back in CBS right I've not seen the
film I can't comment on the film but but
boy did that career go up in smoke and
you know what what you know when that
wouldn't have happened that wouldn't
have happened before the internet that
would not have happened if he if he had
pulled that stunt in about nineteen
eighty-five when he was anchoring the
CBS Evening News there would've been a
very different response the reason why
he was held accountable was because of
bloggers and because of independent
investigators and even non professional
journalists looking into things like
typewriter fonts right and it wasn't
there you know there what there was I
forget I forget all the details of that
case but but there you know the font and
one of these letters was not available
and when it was tight when was
supposedly typed but it took it took
that level of expertise and i'll tell
you a political reporter at The New York
Times of the Washington Post would not
have found that information even if
they've gone looking it took the sort of
crowdsourcing potential of the internet
for that to come up and to destroy well
he you know he he wasn't destroyed by
other people he destroyed himself but to
let that immolation occur it took the
internet and and that's I think the
lesson here is that the accountability
now is is is different and it's better
well dead yeah we're fall they do it
this way they do it on their they do it
on their phones number one yeah um so
they are almost entirely digital you've
heard the term digital natives I mean
they are just there they're born into
this right I still get my wall street
journal in the mail and I turn the pages
every day and I like doing that and I'm
never going to change and it's just a
function of my age right our students
today newspapers at why would why would
you look at a newspaper right when you
get everything well so that's the second
that's the second part and that's one of
the problems is they don't always know
they don't even know what the right
filters are you know what are the best
sources and when you have when you have
social media you can you can get sent
all over the place with with sources and
so forth what they just they just need
to become intelligent readers and find
sources they trust over time there are a
lot of good news gathering organizations
out there and they need to start
developing the kinds of brand loyalties
we all have some get better or worse but
they just need to be readers of the news
I'm usually just gratified when they're
paying attention to the news right
that's that you know to see the
curiosity in the interest that's that's
you know we can we can get into some of
the deeper questions later but I think
if they're smart and they're genuinely
curious and so on they'll figure out
what the good what the good news sources
are but we do need these filters and
that's why you know everyone's a
journalist well in a sense yeah but you
know we we need really great
journalistic organizations where writers
have editors and you have people
second-guessing things and you have the
guy who's willing to stand up to Dan
Rather and say you know I don't think
this is right you need organizations
that have that kind of built-in
capability and they they do exist they
do exist
politicians of producing material on
weekly more likely a monthly basis in
daily basis newspapers he talked a
little about how journalism has changed
in terms of the velocity news produce
yeah so so that that's exactly what's
happening you know in journalism there's
always been an interest in being first
with the news you know and this was true
with old daily newspapers and everything
you want to be the first to report
something you want to beat the
competition on that even if it's just
you know by an hour or whatever there's
always been a preemie anon that even
when things move slowly compared to
today now it's really you know you want
to be you want to be first to the news
you want to get that Drudge link you
know you want everybody kind of going
back to you as the person who who broke
the story this has created some some
awkwardness because because you know you
can be so fast now you know you're a
tweet away from breaking the news you
know are you sure are you sure with what
you're reporting I remember when
remember when the UM the first Obamacare
decision came out you know we all tuned
to our TVs at ten o'clock in the morning
or whatever it was on a weekday and and
they they had like they had like these
people lined up in the in the Supreme
Court office where they were
distributing the opinion who would
sprint out of the Supreme Court and hand
it over to the news anchor you know as
fast as possible in the news anchor
would like be on live TV like reading
through this thing and I don't know if
you remember this but first the first
thing they started saying within 30
seconds is they've overturned Obamacare
right and then there was you know about
three or four minutes later is like oh
wait wait wait wait we were completely
wrong when we said that right see we're
seeing more of that and it's like you
know why don't we like turn our TVs off
at ten o'clock give them an hour to read
the thing and then come back and tell us
really what happened so often times you
just need to slow down because the only
thing the only thing worse than being
second in the race to the news is being
wrong about the news and we're seeing an
awful lot
from this perspective that you know
first you're last some of these what you
don't want look you want to be quick and
you want to be right and and so there's
a there's I guess there's a balance to
be struck and that's why we need high
quality people making these judgments
and you know so when the Supreme Court
case comes down you actually know how to
read an opinion and see what it says and
start talking about it but but you know
um don't be wrong for heaven's sake in
this so there's there's there's an awful
lot of wrong out there now would because
of the pressure to be to be first which
has always existed but which is more
intense now do we have a question over
here different opinions happy that they
have I will I live life are stones
Fox CNN BBC and it is my love how the
same of that can be reported in ways
that I can't believe anything other than
people are being in this life are they
willing to slip I think of Benghazi
hearings last week got to that I said
because I did want to get instead and
and how most of the oil the
grandstanding wonderful sell to us these
were the emails and this is what she
said yeah so so one ones one store one
story is we finally nailed her we know
she's a liar now right that was and then
the other one was boy she deflected
those questions well right and and and
you know way to go Hillary yeah that's
that's a that's a real problem there is
a there is it there there it is there
there is a there is a strengthened the
diversity though because a generation
ago you would have only gotten the one
now we get both and so it allows a kind
of raucous debate and we can worry about
people talking past each other and
that's a problem and I hate to see it
and we all hate to see it because I want
a kind of engagement here on the one
hand on the other hand the conversation
was completely one-sided a generation
ago now at least it's two-sided and I
think we'll be better at getting at the
truth and if somebody really wants if
somebody really wants to find out what
people said about Benghazi and what
really happened there are still some
unanswered questions obviously both a
little bit of research I think we can we
can get at the truth and if you remove
blinders you'll you'll be able to make
judgments about people and decisions and
so forth how where's
the arguing is that
from various sources yeah most studies
indicate most people actually follow the
news closely actually do go and search
out alternative viewpoints and and so it
sounds like you do that yourself a
little bit and that can be frustrating
but I you know I I often want to know
you know what are they thinking on NPR
right I'm kind of curious about that and
and and so how do we look up yeah look
so so in the wild world of you know
1790s journalism and the kind the kind
that I'm suggesting we're headed towards
today they're going to be a lot of
problems there's going to be a lot of
mistakes they're going to be there's
gonna be a lot of unfairness but it's in
its way it's kind of better and it's
better for us as conservatives because
now last we're actually being heard yep
entire media I would just like to know
why the left has so much exposure why
they have tremendous yeah so so um
there-there there's a lot to go in here
say about that one of the most important
things though is not enough
conservatives have gone into journalism
they've chosen not to do it and they've
chosen not to do it for some really good
reasons you know why not go start a
business why not go do another thing why
would you go into a profession that is
by reputation so dominated by liberals
you know I don't yeah I don't I don't
mind you know you can save yourself I
don't mind working with liberals but are
they going to give me the promotions
that I'm going to earn you know is it
going to be fixed if they're not fair
with their news coverage are they going
to be fair in the newsroom so you can
understand why conservatives would would
would steer away from it on the other
hand on the other side journalism it's
always been a little bit adversarial it
has certainly since Woodward and
Bernstein had a kind of let's change the
world let's be champions of this or that
cause you know and so what we have here
is a phenomenon that it attracts
liberals and it ran it and it repels
conservatives and as a result is we
don't know what conservatives going into
the field and so one of my messages to
conservatives you guys have never had it
easier to the young ones right if you're
thinking about their job prospects so
it's like oh my goodness you know I get
a call every week from somebody saying I
need I want to hillsdale student right
not only get in line and you don't pay
them a lot of money because there's
there's there's practically a bidding
war for our students and it'sit's and
it's the demand for conservatives who
can write well and work hard is so
strong you know we need to correct this
we need to correct this human capital
deficit on our
we need to produce more good
conservatives in every kind of field but
but journalism we're just crying out for
them and when we start producing more
we're going to what some of these
problems will begin to improve we are
time for one more question yes is it
becoming very entrenched in the Justice
Department for a good price and and it's
now work is right at PAP and I don't
know if you're aware but mass dagger has
just been labeled in Naples story that
with every where the way that SPLC would
want them so there's a big movement and
suggestions from you on what can be done
to make sure these people are not
credential because they're they're
casting key conservatives you think why
hillsdale does as extremists which falls
into this whole thing that Bond's doing
the case real extreme
right so this I think you're referring
to the Southern Poverty Law Center it's
like violence extremism project right
where they you know what what are the
examples of violent extremism in
American society and of course there's
you know terrorism as we traditionally
understand it and we've seen inflicted
upon our country but they're also
talking about I think they named the
Family Research Council as an extremist
organization right this is an
ideological group and it has you know
Southern Poverty Law Center like who's
against poverty right they have one of
these names that that sounds that sounds
well who could be against that right but
it turns out they have a deeply
ideological agenda and and i think i
think you know we need it we need we
need to educate first of all readers and
voters that you know who they are and
what they say is not to be trusted then
secondarily call out the journalists who
cite them is if their unbiased sources
over the Southern Poverty Law Center's
identified such and such as an extremist
group well there's you know there's
something going on here but when we have
an environment when you know Becky Quick
can talk about 77 cents on the dollar I
mean you know how far are we away from a
Republican presidential debate where
somebody sites this organization as if
its authoritative I think we've got to
call them on and we got to do it through
social media and do it fast alright
folks thanks a lot